g'day my name is Henk a cot well and I'm
rich Hyndman welcome to this week in
Android development for Monday second of
sep tember 2013 something's been
irritating us for a while and with red
hair away this week we're going to fix a
bunch of his spelling mistakes try as we
may to remove rato altogether he
continues to haunt us last week rato
showed us how to analyze transfer
profiles I have no idea what that means
but I guess we should watch the dev bite
right Daniel tried to hold his fragments
together and help you do so as well and
in this week's episode of dev biol is
that all that dashing person that's
Chris Broadfoot I don't know who the
other guy is nice t-shirt anyway they're
going to be kicking off a dead bite
series on building better maps apps and
rato is going to be showing us some more
cool android cartoons with little to no
relevance to actual coding dan is going
to show us how to perform card flip
animations from inside a donut and game
on is back again for another episode to
show us how to integrate controllers
with your android games how did they get
away with it without them so far it's
not that hard is it and Shazam Sam has
been updated with tablet-optimized
layouts and a great app icon animations
yeah check that out excellent so that's
all for this week in Android development
be sure to check out this week's dev
bytes as well and remember it's our
party we can do what we want it's our
party we can say what we want